hey guys it's national puppy day today
so I decided to throw together this
little video I'm a little bit upset
because I didn't know about this ahead
of time but here are some baby puppy
videos of the love of my life
DJ mini Matt you guys can follow him on
Twitter and Instagram you can also
follow me but my dog so much cuter
happiness will update yourself up ahead
of you look how big you are you're a big
puppy now no I candle
mheg are you thank you
Oh Maddie first car ride
Oh
you said the fire zone to your promise
you've got
religion
Oh
and now you can too
it's like
oh you're sorry but you
and
that we have
we window
we have to cool
I got you Barry
you got
if you want
Oh
we went down
we were
making his meal
let's go come on
and now here's our big baby Maddy come
on go over here oh sit
hi MA hi hi I got it
in for our grand finale FISMA good boy
yeah happy international puppy day tweet
me some pictures of your puppy if you
liked this video please like it and if
you enjoy puppy videos make sure you
subscribe to my channel because there's
definitely not a shortage of those here